[Music]
if your has this unique ability to
really take you there and that's sort of
a something I've been trying to do in
traditional still images and documentary
film and and and those mediums have a
great power to influence but I was
always frustrated with the inability to
really take a first-person subjective
experience and let someone see it for
themselves and VR can start to do that
I can place people into worlds that they
may never otherwise see and experience
something firsthand in a way that is
very different than watching a film you
recall it as a memory instead of I saw a
movie I actually was there in this
experience and so those memories
actually encode in a in a stronger way
and I think that allows us to reflect
and process them in a more personal way
you have an emotional connection and you
get as close to being in their position
as possible it's not completely a
first-person perspective and there's
there's some testing and research around
that where could we actually embody
someone else that's a little bit harder
but right now we know we can bet least
be very close and when you are very
close to someone and you're seeing what
they're experiencing you start to
internalize that we have these mirror
neurons that we can feel what other
people are feeling and that reflection
that I think is invoked from these
powerful experiences can start to foster
empathy for the other and it can
dissolve your own ego and help you take
the perspective of someone else and I
think this special ability of VR is
really important for the the urgent
crisis that we're facing especially
climate change which it can be hard to
dig into to really lean into because it
seems so big and abstract and but when
you are experiencing climate change
right in the places that
it's it's happening you feel like it's
it's here that you're getting this
glimpse into the future of a world of
extreme weather of dried out desert
conditions of refugees of pristine
ecosystems collapsing and being
destroyed and so when you can actually
experience these events as if you were
there you internalize them and I think
that starts to lead to this process of
well am i participating in it am i
consuming fossil fuels that I don't need
to can i divest from some of the
industries that are responsible for this
crisis and so I think that reflection
was really important because it leads to
or is necessary to lead to action in
one's own life and there's a whole
threshold of different actions one can
take to engage with this this incredible
environmental problem that we're facing
and so you know this chain of events I
think can be triggered through a
singular powerful experience and so with
this medium we can convey not just
information we can convey emotional
fidelity in a way that we haven't been
able to do with with such clarity and so
we can really feel what it's like to be
a mother in the deserts of Somalia
trying to find food for her children and
and having to flee to the outskirts of
cities into huge camps and and seeing
that they're really just trying to care
for their families just as we would do
if we were there and so I think it has
this ability to help us invoke the
empathy that we all have and cultivate
the compassion and the action that is
needed to address so many of the world's
problems
you